Tim Couch Oh joining us on loan from
Dallas Morning News and are we
interrupting and around the horn
pre-show meeting 511 192 technically by
the time I hang up the conference call
will of the gun I will be late
thank you very much probably cost me
three points how long does the pre-show
meeting last does it last longer than
the actual show itself depends on
Woody's on the show I knew it yes as I
said woody probably has a funny line or
tries to have a funny line with every
topic the second one you said tries to a
little less than an hour to do the
conference call now they're doing stuff
you know they're doing they're getting
it ready I'm just talking about the the
talent portion of the show on the
conference panel your talent now huh
okay well now what do they they give you
all the topics that you're gonna have
and yes we go over all the topics and
sometimes we moved them around based on
well this one wasn't that interesting
but this thing we had down here and buy
or sell let's move that up to the a
block hmm and because we have a better
discussion there there you have it okay
that's how the sausage is made
is there any controversy at all I guess
there ever has anybody ever really
gotten mad at somebody else yes yeah
okay so Jay Mariani
I didn't say any name no you did not you
did not but Jay Mariani got upset with
who oh I don't know he might he might he
was very competitive he's very
competitive do you think you could win
Mariani when we went out of day after
day and he'd be the best of me now and
then and and and then I got the best of
him in a book I wrote so we uh you know
we went back and forth no
about a fight like you against Mariano
well I've got some size on short little
fella I don't know he might be surprised
it could be a wrestler now I'd have to
look at it here you can always tell a
wrestler you just look at their ears so
they got a collar for three different
directions and that was all I wanted to
talk to you about Tim set the scene are
you on around the horn today because of
the Dez Bryant topic I'm on because I'm
scheduled
I assume the Dez Bryant topic will be
part of the show okay although you know
there's another problem as long as we're
peeling back layers here and showing how
the sausage is made when we think
something is going to happen before five
o'clock Eastern sometimes we have to
avoid it like a day baseball playoff
cave or something you know like well we
can't talk about that because that's
going to be over by the time we on the
air so and nobody really knows nobody
has a clue what's going to happen today
it wouldn't surprise me if Jerry Jones
talks to dance for two hours and never
even brings up the contract Jerry just
talks wouldn't be surprised if they
announced they're releasing in today I'd
be very surprised if there was some sort
of announcement that we've we've come to
termed on any kind of deal regarding his
contract so I think it's either just
like no news coming out of it or we've
decided to part ways what's Dallas's
draft strategy well I think regardless
of the DES thing that they're 19 and
they want a wide receiver they need a
middle linebacker they lost Anthony
Hitchens to the Chiefs so they could go
linebacker first-round wide receiver
second because there's always a lot of
good wide receivers in the second round
there are this year but they in Jason
Garin the whole staff went to Alabama to
work out Calvin Ridley so that that
could be a very big possibility I get a
wide receiver in the first or second
round they're going to they're gonna
have to they got Allen Hurns who's a
nice player but I don't know that he's
beyond that although one middle one
little tidbit you and the Dan hats
probably don't know
how many more yards do you think Sammy
Watkins had over the last three years
Sammy Watkins we got 48 million dollars
then Allen herds I would take Allen
Hurns okay well Sammy Watkins at 78
yards more over the last three years
okay but I'm saying the Cowboys got him
two years 12 million Chiefs got Watkins
three years 48 million with 20-some
guaranteed yeah I like their pretty much
they're pretty much the same stats year
after year yeah but they need a number
one receiver that's the problem I have a
Dallas right and I don't think herds is
that he might be known to his health but
so that's why your first or second-round
pick this year or by next year needs to
be your number one receiver
your favorite Jerry Jones draft day
story is what oh gosh you know I don't
know it was very in the old days in the
90s remember they used to do contracts
with players while they were on the
clock and the league made him stop them
because they would talk to different
players and saying we're going to not
tell me god I think Russell Maryland
with the first pick they thanked
somebody else if you don't take this
deal and the league eventually made him
so that's not how we do things here but
I don't know he might wasn't he taken
Johnny Manziel you know I think that's a
little overstated I mean he certainly
once it fell to him he was interested
but the idea that he had some card ready
to turn in I don't think it got that
close forever everybody who's talked
about that he he was interested Stephen
and all the scouts and the coaches were
not and they talked him down on that one
it would have been more entertaining but
Jack Barton has turned out to make the
all-pro team every year so probably a
good thing that they didn't if you would
look at the draft status at Troy Aikman
Emmitt Smith and Michael Irvin and fast
forward to today's NFL if they were
coming out of college right now how do
you think we would look at their there
their skill set and and personalities
and baggage going into the draft
you know Michael's baggage going into
the draft wasn't that significant he'd
had very minor the you know stuff at
Miami he would be right you know Troy
would still be toy would be regarded the
way he was I mean he would be regarded
as who's a recent carson wentz but from
using a clay i'm juggling the big
strong-arm make all the throws but he's
played at UCLA okay mom almost like
andrew lock but maybe but not below
andrew luck I would say okay even though
he's he went on to have a great career
we don't know about Andrew
Emmett you got to remember 17th pick and
the Cowboys spent that whole draft
trying to get defensive players they
tried to get James Francis they tried to
get Alomar Lathan and when they couldn't
get him Jimmy finally said you guys go
ahead and take your dress take your
running back because they had just
signed Kara traded for Terrence Flagler
you gotta remember all the running back
Aaron's flying her from the 40 that they
had traded for Daniel Stubbs you know
it's Flagler a couple days before the
draft and they thought Flagler was just
starting or anything but so Emmitt you
know would be viewed as a guy who runs
about a four six and he's running back
how valuable is that today so he would
try to be discredited the boats even
though he's the one that with under
18,000 yards if you call in right now to
the around the could you call in right
now while we're on the radio could you
college us the show in that's you could
you patch in the show to around the horn
I've got some hot takes for real okay
okay next time I would like to punt you
know be punched into the around the
Horan conference company to do sky
points on Mike and Mike on the show that
used to be called Mike and Mike and that
didn't go well I would not do that to
America I would not do that to them you
give me the phone number to the
conference call right now in the arm and
then we could just call in
I can't do it okay
privately I was a little text message
okay something like that yeah we did
we'll get you involved how many points
have you more involved how many yeah I'm
sure you do how many points do you think
you cost yourself by being on this show
today by being late it specifically
being late to do this show which I've
got I'm gonna say it's a five-point
deduction and that's that right there
that takes me off the show down I have
no chance against Sarah Spain with that
sort of loss yeah so I did a few all
right well I appreciate that
according for the VP so and I'm gonna
watch I'm gonna watch today anything
specific how about you don't wear pants
see what he paid strikes me as a guy who
may not wear pants might not how about
this you wear a kilt today and then
stand up at some point
how many kilts do you have like be
honest with all right we'll make me
proud today you know I think kilts are
underrated man I tell you if I do a
little like like Carol Burnett thing
where I kind of tweak my nose my ears
yes
how about you run your fingers through
your hair I'm at the front of the line
could you do that maybe just like just
tossin you know just like a little flip
or something
yeah a little hair flip okay well yeah
we're gonna and we're gonna add to the
audience by about four or five people
today so that that's a page I would
think that gets us up another rating boy
that's good that keeps us out of highly
questionable thank you Tim thank you
guys that's that's Tim Keller Sean
he's uh he's a Cowboys insider or
something like that
he works for Dallas Morning News
of course around the horn for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]